pour éviter le grand feu il y a deux
volets qui ont exactement la même
importance le premier volet c'est la
préparation de la forêt à éviter le feu
ou tout au moins à ce qu'on puisse en
défendre facilement et le deuxième volet
c'est les moyens qu'on peut mettre en
face pour lutter contre le feu quand le
feu a démarré
donc pour les pompiers les deux volets
sont aussi importants par contre
agrotech Paris dans le cadre de la
valeur du sauver nous démontre que 1
euro investi pour protéger la forêt ça
permet d'économiser 20 à 25 euros quand
il faut la défendre contre le feu donc
on a tout intérêt à faire ce travail
préventif
suite
à notre rapport et puis à la proposition
de loi que nous avions lancée
pratiquement tous les sujets ont été
retenus on a beaucoup travaillé sur la
préparation de la forêt à éviter
l'incendie et en particulier sur les Old
donc
beaucoup de sujets pour informer au
maximum la population et impliquer déjà
à faire ses old un point négatif quand
même c'est que bon on a mis en place le
bateau qui convient mais nous on avait
prévu au Sénat qui est un peu la carotte
aussi c'est à dire que les
les obligations légales de
débroussaillement puissent être
défiscalisés en partie bon ça on a eu
une opposition flagrante de Bercy qui a
pas voulu mais on y reviendra
pendant au prochain PLF parce que c'est
pour nous c'était pour nous une mesure
phare qui allait déclencher ses
opérations aux endroits où jusqu'à
maintenant ça traîner
on perdait du temps là c'est une façon
de d'accélérer les choses dans les
mesures positives il y a aussi
l'interdiction de fumer en forêt on sait
que le feu de Gonfaron en 2021 il est
parti d'un mégot de cigarettes après il
y aura aussi
des aménagements pour qu'il fallait
absolument que on est beaucoup plus de
pompiers volontaires jusqu'à maintenant
chaque fois que on avait des gros soucis
sur les territoires méditerranéens ou
landais il y avait des renforts qui
venaient d'un partout dans la France
mais à partir du moment où les feux se
déclenchent un peu de partout ces
renfort peut-être seront mobilisés ces
jeux chez eux et pourront plus venir en
renfort ce qui veut dire que sur les les
200 000 pompiers je inclus les
volontaires là-dedans là il y aura pas
assez il en faudrait 50 minutes de plus
donc il faut générer des vocations et
faciliter les choses et dans le texte là
on défiscalise des entreprises qui
libéreront leurs employés au moment des
feux pour faciliter les choses donc une
expérience une expérience sur trois ans
on espère que elle sera efficace et
productive et qu'on pourra la
généraliser et puis la généraliser aussi
au public